[Music]
and now please let's welcome ian cook
hi good afternoon so uh 2020 this year
marks the 50th birthday of sql
sql or sql if you prefer is of course
the
database query language that's
ubiquitous today
um its origins date back to 1970 when
edgar f codd
at ibm published this seminal paper that
established the theoretical basis
for sql it took a few more years after
this actually before the language
as we know it today came into being r by
comparison is younger the first version
dates back to the early 90s although its
precursor s
also dates back to the 70s so
let's do a show of hands raise your hand
if you know at least some
sequel if you've used it okay almost
everyone in the room
is a little bit familiar at least with
sql so put your hands down and second
question
now raise your hand if you learned sql
before you learned
r okay most people in this room um even
here at
our conference uh seems like most people
learn sql first or at least a a good
share
in the broader population vastly more
people
use sql than r and most people who who
use r
learn sql first if you
work in industry especially you'll often
see lots of anecdotal evidence for this
and it's borne out by things like the
stack overflow developer survey results
so my my story with r and sql is i first
learned r
in graduate school for statistics but
then when i started when i finished my
degree and started working in industry
i started having to use sql a lot and
i've used both r and sql a great deal
ever since
but over the last year or so i really
leveled up my sequel when i created a
sql focused coursera course
so there's me on video teaching the
coursera learners about a particular
aggregate function in sql
can you guess which one it is based on
my costume come on
count yes it's it's a fun course by the
way
you can check it out there's a link to
it in my twitter bio
um so if you know some sql and you know
r and the tidy verse one of the things
you'll notice
is that sql and dplyr are really like
two
implementations of the same abstract
concept
and they have a whole lot in common
first of all a table
in sql is essentially equivalent to the
concept of a tidy data frame
in r so each variable forms a column
each observation forms a row each type
of ops
observational unit forms a table that's
what we call
tidy data in r but in the world of sql
that is really the essence of edgar f
codd's third normal form which is the
most widely used way of structuring the
tables
in a database and once you have your
data in this kind of structure
whether you call it tidy or third normal
form the types of operations you can
apply to the data
are basically the same in d plier as in
sql
so d plier as i'm sure most most of us
know
provides a set of functions so-called
verbs and the idea is that you can use
just a few of these to do most of the
kinds of data manipulation that you'd
ever need to do
so when hadley created d plier
essentially what he did was he took the
semantics of the sql select statement
and he brought it into r of course the
syntax is different
and hadley did depart from from sql in a
few notable ways but the similarities
are you know really striking
so if you're familiar with sql then
you'll recall the clauses
of the sql select statement select from
where group by having order by and limit
are the main
clauses and each of these maps onto
a d player verb but it's not exactly a
clean
one-to-one mapping so let me go through
this the from clause
in sql i'll start there it just
specifies what table to use so in dplyr
you do that by specifying just the name
of a data frame
of course you have to load the data in
or point to it
of course in the case of using multiple
tables with a join it's a bit
a bit different the select statement in
sql
has several different roles uh the
select list i should say
so it corresponds to different d plier
verbs depending on what you're trying to
do if you're just grabbing
existing columns then that's a select in
d plier
if you're using expressions to define
new columns
that's mutate or transmute and if you're
using
aggregate functions in that case select
corresponds to summarize
in dplyr the where clause
in a sql select statement corresponds to
filter
group by corresponds very nicely to
group by
having in sql that's the clause that you
use
to filter by groups after aggregating
and in d plier you would use filter for
that but you'd use it
after group by and then order by
that corresponds to a range in d plier
and
finally limit that's just head or slice
if you if you prefer and incidentally
you know it's not just d plier
and sql that have this same underlying
abstraction layer
this has proven to be such a successful
one that it's been widely adopted
pandas and python spark in the big data
world many many more tools
for working with data all follow the
same semantics to varying degrees i mean
some like dplyr adopted it from the
start
others kind of backfitted to it later
anyway one of the great things about
this common abstraction
underlying both sql and dplyr is that
it's enabled dplyr code to be translated
into sql allowing you to use dplyr to
query databases and this
is enabled by the package db plier
with db plier you can connect to a
database refer to a specific table
in the database and then chain on dplyr
verbs just as if you were working with
an in-memory or data frame
and what db player does is it translates
all those dplyr operations
into a sql select statement uh sometimes
with the help of a custom backend
package like specific to that you know
sql engine
and then finally it uses the dbi package
to run that sql select statement on the
database and return the result back to r
um so just to sh this is kind of small
if you can't see the slides they're in
my github repo
at e m cook on github so sorry about
that size
but here's an example of how dbplier
works so you first define a variable
that's effectively just a pointer to a
database table
um and then here's a oh so in this
example this is just uh creating a small
in-memory sqlite database
and then it's copying the iris data
frame to it um
then you can use db player or sorry then
you can use d plier on that table
in the sql engine just as if it were an
in-memory data frame
and if you're ever curious about what
sql code your dplyr code is being
translated into
db plier has a handy function show query
that will show you the sql that it's
generating
so i've been using db plier for several
years i've made a few small
contributions to it and i developed a
custom back-end package
for it but i've always wondered like
what about going in the other direction
what about translating sql
to dplyr code i always thought it would
be really cool to have this
uh it could enable you to use sql
statements to query data frames in r
and i searched all around and there was
no existing package that did quite this
sequel to dplyr translation and i
wondered like well why is that
um is it because translating sql to
dplyr is just a really hard problem so
no one's you know
undertaking it or is it because every
everyone is so happy to write dplyr code
to manipulate data that no one wants uh
you know to be able to use sql
to query data frames well there's a
clear answer to this question evidenced
by the popularity of another r package
sql df so this is a well-established
package
it's very popular created by this guy
gabor grotendik
and it lets you run sql queries on our
data frames
but to do this it does not parse your
sql statement
instead it uses a clever trick um the
package
includes an embedded database and it
loads your r data frame into the
database and then runs sql queries
on the database and then returns the
result as an r data frame
uh so here's an example of sqldf at work
the main function has the same name as
the package sqldf
and you pass it just one argument which
is a sql statement enclosed in quotes
and the one part of the sql statement
that it does look at is the from clause
to identify which data frames
um you know you're referring to and it
loads those into the database
uh but it doesn't do any further parsing
of the sql statement it just
passes it over to the database to run
i think sqldf is really cool it
eliminates an obstacle
for users who are proficient in sql and
not so proficient in dplyr
and who just need to get some data
manipulation done in r
so i work as a data science and machine
learning educator at cloudera
and i encounter a lot of learners who
just love this they eat it up
they typically have some experience with
sql and they're really excited that they
can reuse those skills inside
r to do the kind of boring data
manipulation piece and they can move on
to the more exciting stuff like machine
learning and gt plot 2 and shiny apps
which were you know the reasons they
were excited to learn r in the first
place
but there are a couple fundamental
limitations to see
sqldf just inherent to the way it works
that it's important to recognize
like i said it works by copying data out
of r into a database
that's okay for smaller maybe
medium-sized data it does introduce a
bit of latency on the first
query for a particular data frame
because it has to copy it
but subsequent queries are pretty fast
on the same data
however with bigger data it could be
really impractical to make a copy like
this just
like architecturally copying data to a
whole different system like this seems
like a bit of an
anti-pattern it's a clever approach for
sure but it's a
bit of a shortcut solution of the
problem and i have some qualms with uh
with that that way of doing it
second thing what sqldf provides feels
less like a bridge from sequel to r and
more like a dead end i mean
you could just you know refuse to learn
dplyr and just do all your data
manipulation
in r using sql um this just feels wrong
to me i mean i think it's important to
learn dplyr
at some point so a few months ago i set
out to create something that doesn't
have these shortcomings
and it was immediately apparent to me
that this problem breaks down into two
separate pieces one parsing a sql query
into some kind of like abstract
representation
of the data manipulation specified in
the query
and then two actually applying those
data manipulation steps
to the data in our data frames so the
first challenge then was to create a sql
query parser for r
i mean how hard could that be um it
turns out it's pretty hard
so to achieve it i ended up building
kind of a rube goldberg machine
um i created this package called query
parser and it's on cran
the main function in query parser is
named parsequery
it takes a quoted sql select statement
as input
and what it returns is a list with
sub-lists that are named according to
the structure
of the select statement um so you can
see in this example
using the iris table uh the sql
statement has a select clause a from
clause and a group by clause
and the list returned by parsequery has
sub-lists that are named the same
and then the items within the sub-lists
what they are
are unevaluated r expressions
in this example see how there are two
expressions in the select list
in the sql query one returns the species
column one computes the average of the
sepal length column for each species
and these have been translated from
sequel to r and they're each returned
within the select sublist as an
unevaluated r
expression and there are also some
attributes in this list indicating
various properties like whether the
query aggregates
so i'm really proud of a few things
about how query parser works one
it is implemented entirely as r code
with no
imports no depends no compiled code it's
just r
r code calling base r functions and this
makes it easy to maintain
no dependencies are going to break over
time
however there is an option in this
function to use
functions from several tidy verse
packages
in the translations that it outputs this
option defaults to false but you can set
it to true
so in this example for instance uh count
star translates to the dplyr function n
to count the number of rows which is
handy in many cases
query parser performs semantic
translations not literal translations
and a good example of this is how it
translates the sql aggregate expression
sum of one this is commonly used by
folks in the sql community just to count
rows it does the same thing as count
star
but the sum function in r doesn't work
like that so query parser translates
this to the dplyrn
function also the parsequery function
checks all the expressions in all the
clauses
of the query that you pass to it against
a list of allowed
functions and operators and it throws an
error
like this if there's a function or
operator that's not on that list and the
reason i did this is because i'm
imagining that someone will eventually
like build this into a shiny app
where there's a box that allows users to
input a sql query
um and in this case query parser would
allow any malicious inputs
from getting through so the details of
how all this works are enough to fill a
whole different talk
so i'm not going to describe them all
but in the simplest sense it
kind of goes like this uh first it
splits the query into clauses
then it splits the clauses into strings
containing different sql expressions
uh and then it manipulates the strings
to change them from sql expressions to
r ish expressions things that r will
recognize as r code this is the most
uh laborious and unsatisfying part of
the whole process um the code in query
parser
needs to step through every single
expression character by character
keeping track of like when it's inside
quotes
when it's inside parentheses looking for
different kinds of sql syntax and
replacing them with the equivalent r
syntax
it uses this thing called raw
connections inside base r to do that
it's not particularly elegant but it
works um
the next step is it takes those r like
expressions and
it parses them using uh stir to lang
which
uh creates an unevaluated r expression
uh from a string containing
our code and now this is the step that
is satisfying um
after that what happens is this sort of
magical combination of
quoting substitution unquoting deparsing
streaming
string manipulation re-parsing some of
this is what you know
you might call quasi quotation in an
arlang context but here it's all done
with base r
um and this is the part that i'd love to
you know do a whole talk about because
it's sort of fascinating how it all
works
after that i have to do a few more
manipulations of the abstract syntax
tree to make everything work exactly
right
then i perform some basic validity
checks and then return
that list that you saw in the previous
uh slide so
all this takes about only a hundred
milliseconds
uh for a simple query maybe like two or
three hundred milliseconds for a more
complex query
it could be much faster for sure but to
the end user just parsing one query
it feels instantaneous so moving on to
the second piece
tidy query this is also on cran and this
is the package that most end users will
actually use
the main function in tidy query is named
query
it takes a quoted select statement as
input and it uses the from clause to
identify which data frame you want to
query
and then it uses the rest of the select
statement to establish how to manipulate
that data frame
performs those manipulations and returns
a new data frame as the result
so basically if you're familiar with sql
df then you use tidy query
uh just the same way but of course it
works differently under the hood
as i'll describe but first there's
another option you can also use
this query function like a dplyer verb
in a chain with other dplyr verbs above
it and below it
um the thing is you just have to leave
out the from clause
because then the data that's passed in
piped in above
becomes the you know the from clause
so despite the syntax of this being
similar to sqldf
under the hood uh this query function in
tidy query works totally differently
the first thing it does is it calls the
parse query function in
query parser then getting back that list
it determines like which sequence of
dplyr verbs it needs to call
to you know execute this query and then
it uses dplyr with the help of r-lang
to evaluate the expressions in the
context of a data frame
um so i should say uh tidy query has
lots of dependencies
query parser is the one that's got no
dependencies tidy query has has lots of
dependencies including r lang
and d plier of course
uh so if you remember the earlier slide
about db plier essentially tidy query is
like
the inverse of db player which hadley
was quick to note
i'm not sure how you say db player
backwards
i'm not going to try currently query
parser and tidy query work for the most
common types of sql
queries they have some limitations uh
i'll i'll not go through these point by
point
in the interest of time but i do have
plans to implement all of this
um but i don't i don't even have any
specific time frames yet if you feel
strongly that you'd like to see like one
of these
uh features implemented sooner rather
than later let me know and i've talked
to several people at the conference
who've
voted for sub queries but find the the
relevant github issue at one of those
links
and let me know you know give it a
thumbs up if if that's the feature you'd
like to see and also
if you try these packages and you notice
that something's broken
or if it's missing a translation for
some function that you want it to use
just create an issue uh include a rep
rex and um
you know uh i i'd love to take a look at
that
so one of the things i'm really excited
about is that tidy query doesn't work
only on our data frames it can work on
any
data object that dplyr can work on so
for example data.table
with hadley's recent overhaul of the dt
plier package
you can use dplyr code with data.table
and it uses lazy evaluation to run
efficiently
on data tables so query tidyquery
preserves that lazy evaluation
and here's an example that works just
like the last one you just have to call
that lazydt function at the beginning to
create that
data.table layer so basically anytime
dplyr works with some data source
tidyquery can work with it
maybe i might have to make a couple
little changes to recognize the class
name
but it'll all work and it won't move the
data it'll query it in place
i'm excited to try this with the new
version of the apache arrow r package
that neil richardson spoke about
yesterday
which now supports the dplyr verbs i
haven't tried it but i'll do that soon
there's one more thing about tidy query
that i'm really excited about so besides
running sql running your sql query tidy
query can also
show you the dplyr code that it
translated your query
into so to do this you use the function
show underscore query
and here's a simple example this is
exactly the same
deployer code that would run if you were
to call the query function and
internally
there's actually just one main function
that runs query and show dplyr
and that function has a great deal of
conditional logic to try to generate the
simplest
possible dplyr code that it can give in
your query um so the the dplyr code ends
up
being basically what you would get if
you wrote it uh you know as a human
uh and here's a more complex example
unless you think i'm cherry picking
simple examples
that will work no it can generate some
really complicated queries with joins
and so forth
and i think for a lot of people being
able to see instant translations from a
language they do understand
uh to one they don't is a really
effective means of learning a new
language so i hope that this provides a
valuable learning and teaching tool
and helps build the bridge from sql to r
thank you
you